blowing your ass play grow the [ __ ] up I
don't think I'll be using that phrase at
all because I think since [ __ ] stupid
[Music]
so the phosphorus we got here as putting
lipstick on a peg and that immediately
makes me think I mean you shouldn't be
putting lipsticks on pegs but it also
reminds me of the seeing you do not
polish it but you can't polish at out
which I think there's some approval
approval nods in the back so I think
that's correct which saw just answered
the question but another idea how do you
see what it's like a fart Mahuta cane
you can't expect something that's so bad
and it's so horrible by just by putting
something nice on her okay
a futile attempt to make something look
better than as see what I said there was
exactly as a new a DM for you and you
can't make a peg look pretty simple by
putting lipstick on it I shall think
pegs are quite pretty
so otherwise with the Paris no no no
bestiality under currency of Monday
Morning Quarterback and Quora bark is an
American thing he like gets morale up
and leads a charge and to walk even if
you're a 40 year old man who walks in
veiners let's have a look someone who's
shaking Gators things ah
could the exact opposite of what I said
and I recently about armchair critic
seeing what the quarterback should have
done I mean I'm still done the [ __ ]
wiser I won't be using that one and this
next one is I got to fall sick and
sobbed Bates last night but this sounds
like a man who's had a good time
I mean this is obviously something
that's been made up by Matt Waite I mean
like your women is gone for base last
night because the smarter than that
first base I believe as as Tom kassing
second base as fondling of the breasts
or tits and third base as what is going
on down there faster in the ass yourself
oh the things one thing I love in this
world that its diagram so the base is us
used to explain the stages of a sexual
relationship
the bases are in reference to baseball
of a popular American sport it gives a
[ __ ] and John Hancock has that caught
does it not say no I would be what
Raymond slang it wouldn't be raining
slight FS America John Hancock
I don't know Eli's a little fatty or of
sorts no just know that as means your
signature named after John Hancock
Hussein to signature and I'm overly
flamboyant we in the US Declaration of
Independence I don't I don't know
anything about right than I everything
it but for me signature I can tell he
was a prank
everyone else just do a nice little day
and we've got a lot of names to go on
here John hand cup said [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
next a sledgehammer to crack it not know
that's just like you've got a very small
problem you're just bringing it back to
[ __ ] you don't need a sledgehammer
crack enough to use Tess proportionate
force or expense to overcome a main a
problem master a sledgehammer as a large
hammer thanks far larger than one
required to break it up Barker I plead
the fifth means and all this the fifth
amendment as the right to remain silent
I believe so pleading the fifth means
I'm not going to answer that question
which is maybe what I should have done I
was generate well yes all know that was
one there's no bet too far yet refused
to answer a question because the baddest
are in CHEM innate oneself the Fourth
Amendment as an American Constitution to
protect success and from
self-incrimination yep I knew that up
[ __ ] creek without a paddle
yeah [ __ ] a few up if you like [ __ ]
kick with up a you're [ __ ] and an
awkward situation are implies in
protector and I see ya [ __ ] a same
thing but I am I mean you should be on
[ __ ] creek in the back plate definitely
don't take the kids to [ __ ] creek and
check leak is not a real place gore
Fagor just a figurative way of
describing
somewhere unpleasant the lack of paddle
is also figurative good to know
explanation unknown origin don't include
it then
and the last one as Bronx cheer and I
don't know what this means the Bronx
took place in New York
Chea as an exclamation so we just kept
along blue on your raspily grew all the
[ __ ] up I don't think I'll be using that
phrase at all because I think it's
[ __ ] stupid
thanks very much for watching that
though do they won yes that eagle we're
just shooting the breeze it's fracking
it Hey
[Music]